hi good night everybody  I'm running to serve Pennsylvania but  going to those kind of emotional schools  able to create a career to wait to  excuse me to Wayne Uh rage a lot of very  uh High salary and again supporting to  reduce those costs are critical too I'm  an independent by the way I was  definitely leaning towards fetterman and  I think I have totally changed to the Oz  side why didn't have command of the  facts I do think his condition  unfortunately is going to affect his  ability to do the job I thought Oz uh  was pretty clear on the issues and I  thought he presented himself well and uh  definitely threw out some plans where I  didn't I cannot imagine I genuinely  cannot but I will if we can find video  of it I will gladly play it tomorrow if  you find me video of anyone I mean  literally anyone please send it to us of  somebody that was like I watched that  debate last night and I thought John  Federman was excellent